Public health officials here in New York City...
…have said that now they will be focusing on getting the monkeypox vaccine...
...to those people who have not received the first dose.
And, of course, this puts into question if this is going to put at risk...
…those who have already received the first dose.
Complete chaos.
That's what New Yorkers are calling the process to get monkeypox vaccines in the city.
When I went to go get the shot, they said to me,...
"Well, we're not really, we're not scheduling shots for the second dose...
…because we don't know if we're gonna get them."
Albert Lewitin, a New York media executive,...
...is one of a handful to get the first shot...
...and, like others, is uncertain he will get the second one.
That doesn't mean we don't agree that a two shot dose is ideal,...
…but we are in an environment of increasing cases,...
…extreme demand, and extremely constrained supply.
We do believe one shot does confer significant protection...
…if not as much as two shots.